Stefan, wir können nicht jede Folge mit 20 Minuten Diskussion anfangen, warum und ob du einen kaputten Kopfhörer hast, dein Gehör ist kaputt. Stefan, sieh es ein. Okay, mein Gehör ist kaputt, gut. Wie lebt man als Mensch mit ohne Gehör? Was muss ich jetzt machen? Im Dunkeln. Muss ich jetzt immer wie jemand, der auf einem Ohr nicht sieht, eine Augenklappe, quasi eine Ohrenklappe auf einem Ohr haben? Gibt es einen Superheld, der nicht hören kann? Es gibt auch der Devil, der nicht sehen kann. Und der muss dann alles, der muss dann immer so Aaaaaaah! Aaaaaah! Echo? Und dann kann er durch das Echo hören. Das Echo, weil er genau weiß, wo er ist. Federmausmann, warum muss er nicht Federmausmann, wenn er mit Ultraschall checken kann, wo er ist. Sieh an, sieh an, Der Devil, so sehen wir uns endlich. Aaaaaah! Aaaaaah! Hallo, ich auch, ich, er will immer einen coolen Spruch drücken, er muss leider davor immer A davor immer so, endlich bin ich da. Aber hören Fledermäuse eigentlich ihr, also die stossen den Schall aus und dann daran, wie ihr zurückkommt, kennen sie die Umwelt. Das ist richtig. Aber hören die das gegenseitig auch? Ich glaube, es ist ein ongoing Schreien bei denen. Wenn du bei denen, in deren Schlaf gemächern bist, ist es eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur Aaaaaa, A Ah! Aber ... Ich glaube, es ist anstrengend. Aber die können ja auch schreien, die können auch richtige Geräusche von sich geben. Ich meine, sie müssen es ja selber hören. Also müssen sie auch andere Fledermäuse hören können. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, es ist wie bei Delfinen, die können so Ultraschalldinger lossenden und im Kopf hören sie das. Also wieso ... Die hören das nicht in den Ohren,ren. Nee, ich glaube, die nehmen das anders wahr. Ich glaube, die nehmen das anders, vielleicht auch durch die Ohren, aber ich glaube, es ist keine, nicht auf Schall, die nehmen das nicht als Schall wahr, sondern als als als ein ungefähres Gefühl, wo man hinfahren müsste, so wie ein Navi. Man kriegt so ein ungefähres Gefühl, jetzt gleich in 800 Metern rechts abwiegen, so was ist es. Ja, oder es ist halt eher so ein unbewusstes Ding, sie filtern es raus, so wie man ja die Nase nicht sieht. Was ich mich gerade gefragt habe, ist, warum tragen Leute, die auf einem Ohr taub sind, warum nicht so eine Klappe auf dem Ohr? Weil wenn du auf einem Ohr blind bist, hast du sofort Augenklappe. Kriegst du sofort Augenklappe, komm's her, Augenklappe, next. Aber wenn du auf einem Ohr nichts hörst, kriegst du nicht so einen Plüsch, so einen Kopfhörer auf. Kriegst du nicht, wenn alle direkt sehen, du bist auf einem Ohr. Oder es ist einfach abschliessend, dass man die Ohrmuschel so rüberklappt und dann so festhackt und die Tür zumacht. Einfach so, zack. Nee, das war's, hier passiert nichts mehr. Ich glaube, das war früher mal, das ging früher mal. Da konnte der Mensch so die Tür zumachen bei den Ohrenklapp und dann nichts mehr hören, aber das hat man irgendwann wegrationalisiert. Haben Segelohren einen evolutionären Grund, ist meine Frage. Du, ich sage, Segelohren sind unser Schritt zu Flügeln. Aber alle mobben Leute mit Segelohren, weil sie komisch aussehen. Aber es heißt, nein, Leute, ihr müsst euch mit denen vollpflanzen, so kriegen wir Ohren langfristig, so kriegen wir Flügel. Du hast es auf nicht leicht. Wir haben die gleiche Melodie. Warum? Ne, ach so, Lena. Lena? Lena? Lena? Lisa? Können alle Namen sein. Julia, ihr habt es oft nicht leicht. Ihr habt generische Namen. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Ufo mit Stefan. Tietze und Florentin Will. Ja, vielen Dank. Dankeschön. Wir haben uns wieder gesehen. Ey, ohne Scheiß, wir dachten letzte Woche, wir machen jetzt jede Woche ein Fan-Intro. Bis wir unser richtiges Intro bekommen. Diese Rubrik ist jetzt schon wieder vorbei, weil wir haben nur eins eingeschickt bekommen. Ja, aber falls ihr da draußen noch Lust habt, was zu komponieren, euch mal schön mit dem Dirigierstock... Ja, dann habt ihr Pech gehabt, denn die Rubrik ist jetzt vorbei. Wir haben sie abmoderiert. Das war's. War's. Wie geht's dir, Florentin? Wir sehen uns jetzt immer nur noch wöchentlich. Ja, ganz gut. Aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, dass wir uns nur noch wöchentlich sehen. Ja, wir können uns immer von unseren verrückten Abenteuern erzählen. Hier, was mich wundert, mir ist gerade, ich hätte mich fast gerade selber eingesperrt auf der Toilette, weil da gibt es einen Schlüssel. Wimmern hat man gehört und nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt. Da gibt es einen Schlüssel, also es gibt ja zwei Arten von Schlössern. Einmal, ich nenne es das Fixschloss, wo der Riegel schon mit im Schloss ist. Also du kannst keinen Schlüssel rausziehen. Oder es ist ein Knaufers. Ja, es ist kein Knauf, das ist ein Schalter. Ja, naja, so eine Art Schalter. Man versteht, was meins. Dieser Halbmond, dieser Halbkreis. Ah, na, ist das ein Halbmond? Nee, also ich sehe da mehr so eine Ovalette, also so eine längliche Ovale. Und da kannst du dran drehen, das sind die Advanced Clos haben das, wo man direkt mitgedacht hat, das ist eine Tür zur Toilette, die musst du häufiger mal abschliessen können. Und dann frage ich mich, warum wurde das hier nicht gemacht? Da hat man sich für Schlüsselloch und Schlüsselthematik entschieden, mit dem Hintergedanken, na ja, vielleicht will man ja, vielleicht ist es die Schlüssellobby, dass wenn der Schlüssel verloren geht, schwer zu sagen. Ich glaube, es ist billiger, sehr viele Türen, die gleich sind, zu kaufen. Dann kriegst du Rabatt. Und dementsprechend ist eine sehr rationale Erklärung, aber ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum man einfach, weil die genauso abschließbar ist wie alle anderen, die man hier hat. Wer entscheidet, welche Türen noch so eine Glasscheibe drin haben und welche nicht? Glasscheibe? Also manchmal Glasscheibe, manchmal gemilcht, manchmal so gewobbelt. Oh, oder hier, unsere Tür hier oben hat so ein Luftdurchlassding, so eine Lüftung, Lüftungsschlitz. Und tatsächlich hat mich mein Schornsteinfeger angeschissen, also der, und die kommen ja immer lächerlich früh, also zu früh, um zu begreifen, was für Informationen man gerade von ihm gesagt bekommt. Ich wandle dann immer so in Boxershorts zum Telefon, weil ich gar nicht weiß, was gerade klingelt. Dann gehe ich zur Tür, dann mache ich so auf und dann tatsache ich ihm auch so ein Gesicht. Wer sind Sie gerade? Und dann ist der Schornsteilfegel, dann geht er einfach durchgehen und dann geht er hinten in mein Bad und dann hat er gesagt, sind Sie wahnsinnig? Sind Sie bescheuert? Sie haben keinen Lüftungsschlitz in Ihrer Tür. Haben Sie ein Rad ab? Und ich habe gesagt, was soll ich denn machen? Ja, und dann ist halt meine Tür einfach, ist eine ganz normale Tür, ohne Luftdurchschloss. Und daher die die Heizung, der Gaskeiz, der Boiler, Thermalstation, die ist halt in meinem Bad. Und das darf nicht sein, da muss halt in der Tür eine Luftschleuse sein. Damit die Wärme rauskommt oder damit? Ich glaube, falls Gas austritt, damit das Gas in die ganze Wohnung eindringt. Damit sagt man, ja, also wenn explodiert, dann richtig. Dann in in den Nachrichten. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Hast du jetzt vor deine Tür zu ändern oder hast du da jetzt ein paar Löcher reingeschraubt? Er hat gesagt, ändern wir sofort. Das ist vor einem halben Jahr gewesen. Kann man da nicht so etwas sagen wie Sie haben mir gar nichts zu sagen, Sie sind ein Schornsteinfeger? Ja. Ich habe nicht viel Respekt vor Schornsteinfeger, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Es gibt ja einen großen Hype, uhuhuhu, aber ich habe vor denen keinen Respekt.
Stimmt, es gibt einen Hype, ne?
Die werden ja auch irgendwann in so einer Zeit, wo alle diese Dinger getragen.
Haben die, das frage ich mich tatsächlich immer, tragen die immer noch alle schwarz?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Und haben die dann auch diesen Ball, diesen Draht, diesen Morgensternartigen Ball, den
kennt man doch von Schadensteinfegen, den sie dann reinlassen und dann machen die was sauber mit.
Ja, dann bürsten die da den Rus weg.
Ja, und Leiter, haben die noch Leitern? Bringt die noch Glück?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, das wird immer immer rausgepatcht, glaube ich, irgendwann. Ich weiß nur, dass man gut Rus sagt.
Gut Rus. Also dann gab es irgendwann mal so ein Schornsteinfeger-Meeting, wo man irgendwie so alle zusammengerufen hat, so heute nochmal so ein Monday-Meeting, Montag, alle kommen zusammen, Punkt eins, wir bringen kein Glück mehr, Punkt zwei, niemand so in der letzten Reihe, was, was, schmeißt alles hin, hängt seine Stahlkugel an die Wand, hängt seinen Morgenstern an die Tür, ja, weiß ich nicht, ich weiß auch nicht. Was bringt dir noch Glück? Kleeblätter. Kleine Schweinchen. Vierblättrige Kleeblätter. Alles, was aus Marzipan ist per se.
Ja, primär Schweinchen. Vierblättrige Kleeblätter. Alles, was aus Marzipan ist per se. Ja, aber primär Schweinchen aus dem Marzipan. Ich habe in meiner Kindheit richtig viel Zeit damit verbracht, vierblättrige Kleeblätter zu suchen. Ich dachte, Marzipan zu essen. Ich dachte, du sagst Marzipan essen. Ich war mir sehr sicher. 70-30, aber ich habe nie eins gefunden. Nie. Ja, stimmt. Ich habe auch sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht. Die kann, ne, und dann wurde's auch irgendwann lame. Ja. Dann kann man die züchten und dann wachsen nur noch die ... Ja. Gut. So, jetzt müssen die Notizen hervorrufen. Das war Improvisation, jetzt kommt ... Wo sind die Gags? Gib mir eine Sekunde, gib mir eine Sekunde. Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, hier.
So, zwei Kilobyte.
Kennst du das, wenn man im Meeting sitzt und man schreibt mit jemandem in dem Meeting und der macht einen Witz und dann schickt man zurück, ha ha ha ha, aber der sieht, dass man nicht lacht, derjenige sieht, dass man keine Reaktion gezeigt hat. Ja.
Das haben wir oft gemacht bei guter Arbeit, wenn Leute da waren, externe Leute, über die wir die ganze Zeit gelästert haben.
Dann haben wir über Slack, haben wir mit unserer Kommunikationszule miteinander geschrieben und dann kam es oft so ein Moment, wo jemand ha ha ha ha. Aber dieses, der lacht offensiv. Ha ha ha ha geschrieben. Man sieht in der Wahrheit keine Reaktion. Ja, und dann ist das Vertrauen eigentlich für immer gebrochen, weil man weiß, ab dann immer, wenn die Person ha ha ha schreibt, lacht sie nicht wirklich. Ich finde, es ist immer ein Unterschied, je nachdem, mit wem man schreibt. Ich bin jetzt Chamäleon. Ich bin ein Chamäleon-Texter. Ich schreibe, je nachdem, mit wem ich schreibe, immer anders. Verwandte benutzen oft Smileys, die sind oft eine andere Generation. Ja, ganz interessant. Je älter die Leute werden, desto mehr Emojis verwenden. Ja, und je mehr Emojis mein Gesprächspartner benutzt, desto mehr benutze ich auch, weil ich Angst habe, sonst, das funktioniert nicht. Also es ist wie eine andere Sprache, das ist so, als ob ich dann einem Spanier dann auf Deutsch einfach antworte, ganz normal. Ich habe ein schlechtes Gefühl dabei, wenn ich dann nicht auch Smileys mache.
Ja. Und bei dir zum Beispiel kann ich sein, wer ich bin.
Oh, das freut mich. Das ist ein nettes Kompliment.
Ich schreibe keine Smileys, oft keine ... Viele Beleidigungen, viel Antisemitismus.
Viele Beleidigungen, viele Wörter, die nicht existieren, die ich mir selber ausgedacht habe. Das funktioniert ganz gut bei dir eigentlich. Und sonst, ich bin immer ein Spiegelbild dessen, wie der andere schreibt eigentlich. Ich bin nicht selbstbewusst genug, um selber den meinen, ohne Smileys, knallhart, knochentrocken zurückzuschreiben. Wir haben ja erfolglos versucht, die Emoji-Welt zu verändern. Und ich würde sagen, wir rudern da zurück. Und zwar habe ich einen neuen Zweck ins Leben gerufen. Und zwar, ich will ein paar Emojis loswerden. Es gibt zu viele Emojis. Es gibt zu viele Emojis. Und es gibt zum Beispiel vier Ordner-Emojis. Und ich will, dass der Grüne stirbt. Der Grüne muss weg. Den braucht man nicht. Ordner? Ordner. Welche Ordner gibt es noch? Es gibt den blauen, den roten, den grünen. Wir haben neulich geskypt und dann habe ich kurz einen Einblick in dein Zimmer bekommen, was ich ja fantastisch fand. Das wäre ja ganz interessant. Und im Hintergrund war ein Ordner zu sehen, wo ich mich gefragt habe, was ist passiert? Allein die Vorstellung, dass du dafür in einen Laden gegangen sein musst. Nee, erst mal die Idee, den Wunsch entwickelt haben musst, Ordner dir zu besorgen, in den Laden gegangen bist, die Ordner besorgt hast, die dir gefallen, und du dir in ein Regal gestellt hast. Das finde ich toll. Was ist da drin für mich in der Ordnerwelt? Also, es war so, ich hab ... Es gibt ja manchmal so Dokus. So Dokus? Solche Dokus, die man sich anschaut. Und ich hab so eine Doku gesehen von irgendjemandem, dem es richtig scheiße ging. Nicht der Anfang, den ich erwartet habe. Dem es richtig scheiße ging. Der so richtig keinen Bock mehr hatte, Depression, Schulden, Spielsucht und so richtig, richtig dreckig ging es dem. Also so richtig, wo man sagt, so Kollege, ey, wenn du jetzt nicht was anders machst, dann Das war eine Doku, das war nicht irgendwie die private Videoaufnahme. Das war nicht der Spiegel in meinem Wartezimmer, nein, das war eine Doku und dann hat diese Voice-Over-Stimme, die sehr rational und nüchtern dargelegt hat, warum diese Person komplett den Bach runtergeht, also die Wohnung nicht mehr zu verlassen, ist ein sehr schlechtes Zeichen, die nette Dame, die den Voice-Over gegeben hat, meinte auch, dass der Abbruch von sozialen Kontakten ein schlechtes Zeichen ist. Ja, schon schlecht. Man denkt sich, wenn diese Person die Doku sieht, geht es ihr definitiv noch schlechter. Hat sie den Lösungsansatz bekommen? Keine Lösungsansatz, sie hat nur sehr präzise und konkret analysiert, warum es der Person so schlecht ist. Warum sein Leben lieber runtergeht. Und dann hat diese Voice-Over-Dame auch irgendwann gesagt, Er hat doch irgendwann angefangen, Vorbereiter einen Text vorzulesen, einfach zu kommentieren, was er gerade sieht. Was macht er denn jetzt? Sehr herablassend geworden. Wo macht er das denn? Da steht sein Mülleimer, mitten im Raum steht sein Mülleimer. Und jetzt die zwei Teller abwaschen, das bringt jetzt auch nichts mehr. Komm mal, Bernd, guck dir das an, wie er lebt. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen, wenn das Leben den Bach runtergeht, ist, dass man die Post nicht mehr aufmacht. Oh ja, oh. Weil wenn du viele Rechnungen, Mahnungen bekommst, du denkst dir irgendwann, oh fuck Mahnung, shit, und irgendwann hörst du einfach auf, die Post aufzumachen. Und dann bist du ja, das ist eine Lawine, die nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist, weil irgendwann steht zwangsläufig jemand vor der Tür und schnallt hier so eine Stahlkugel um den Knöchel. Ach so, Schornsteinfee. Und deswegen war das so ein Punkt, wo ich mir dachte so, wupp, Sekunde. Alarm! Kurz mal pausieren. Sozialalarm! Kurz mal pausieren, Doku-Alarm. Ich mach auch meine Post nicht auf. Ich hab bei mir einen grossen Packen Briefe über Jahre hinweg an Posten, die ich nicht aufmache. Ich mache einfach meine Post nicht auf, von Versicherungen, von Leuten.
Ich stelle mir vor, die Wohnung war nicht, als du diese Doku geguckt hast, die Wohnung war nicht ganz erleuchtet, die war so halb dunkel.
Wenn man reinkommt, würde man sagen, mach mal Fenster, mach mal Licht an, sowas würde man mal sagen. Man sieht dich dann, dann sieht man dich, wie du plötzlich zu dieser Stelle kommst und dich auf dich selber projizierst, mit dem grossen, lauten Leertastendruck die Doku anhältst und so zurück, zurück sackst mit deinen Kopfhörern irgendwie, also zurück sackst in dein Sofa und dann durch diese Welle des Zurücksackens kippt irgendwo so ein Briefumschlag, der noch zu war, kippt irgendwie von so einem Stapel Briefe runter. Ja, genau. So war es. Und also ich mach schon,
also wenn ich weiß, was der Brief
ist, dann mach ich ihn auf. Wenn ich nicht
weiß, was der Brief ist, mach ich ihn nicht auf. Und das
ist mein System. Und deswegen hat den grossen Packen
ungeöffneter Briefe. Und ich dachte mir,
fuck, ich muss mein Leben auf die
richtige Bahn bringen. Und ich hab plötzlich
nicht mehr getraut. Ich hab mir so eine Zucker-Doku
angeschaut, dass Zucker unglaublich schlecht
ist. Und dann bin ich in meine Küche gegangen, wo auf Augenhöhe in meinem Regal so ein Kilo Zuckersack stand. Ich dachte mir, du mieses fucking Schwein, du dummer Wichser, warum hast du mir nichts gesagt, wie fucking schädlich du bist und das ist eine weltweite Epidemie, du dumme Sau. Und ich konnte ihn nicht mehr in die Augen gucken. Und so war es bei den Briefen auch. Ihr habt diesen Stapel angeschaltet und gesagt, ey Leute, ihr seid der Grund, warum mein Leben so läuft wie von Klebe. Hast du irgendwann so ein großes Tuch genommen und einfach über die Briefe gelenkt. So, Nacht, ihr schlaft jetzt. Ja, das sogenannte Problemtuch. Das ist auch geil, bei Wellensittichen. Ey, Wellensiche sind so dusselig. Die Idee, einfach, dass sie, unsere, damals, als ich noch klein war, standen wir am Fenster, waren immer laut, nervig und dann irgendwann, okay, das war's für euch. Und dann so ein großes Bettlaken drüber und still. Ich will aber noch wachbleiben, nope, nope, und auch direkt, die schlafen sofort ein, instant, ist ruhig, instant, ist alles egal. Und ich will auch Menschen einfach im Büro manchmal, wenn die nerven, einfach so, okay, das war's, und dann so ein großes Tuch fliegt über die. Vor allem, ich glaube, das einzige Wesen, das wirklich eine Ahnung davon hat, wie es ist, in einem Pokéball zu sein, ist der Wellensittich. So, du läufst rum, alles cool, tagt plötzlich, alles schwarz, alles wächst, du bist nichts und du schläfst einen ganz sicher. Gibt es nicht für Hamster so kleine Kugeln, wo man sie dann auch aus dem Käfig lassen kann? Ich glaube schon, ja. Wo die dann anfangen, wirklich in einem kleinen Pokéball rumzulaufen? Finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Auf jeden Fall. Okay, dann hast du die Ordner geholt. Und ich dachte mir, fuck, das muss enden. Und ich mache jetzt einen Tag und ich kriege mein Leben wieder auf die richtige Reihe. Ich gehe jetzt irgendwo hin, ich kaufe mir Ordner, ich kaufe mir ein Locher, ich kaufe mir eine Schere, ich kaufe mir ein Edding und fange an. Und ein Strick und ein Messer und Blutverdünner und Schlaftabletten und dann mache ich mir einen schönen Tag. Das habe ich dann gemacht und ich habe viel zu viele Ordner gekauft. Ich habe vier Ordner gekauft und habe dann Steuer, Versicherung, Wohnung und jetzt stehen diese Ordner in meinem Schrank und dann habe ich einmal diesen Stapel aufgemacht, jeden einzelnen Brief aufgemacht, es waren zu wirklich 90%
Kontoauszüge. Ja. Und
die interessieren mich in Scheiss, die sind mir
völlig egal, weil ich weiß ja
so, also was, das ist ja man,
das ist ja wie wenn man so ein bisschen
das Drehbuch liest in einem Film, den man schon gesehen
hat, so, ja,
ja und weiter, ich weiß, ich weiß,
ich weiß es schon, und
deswegen habe ich jetzt alles geklärt und ich habe jetzt teilweise meinen Ordner Wohnung zum Beispiel, da sind zwei Zettel drin, in diesem dicken Leitz-Ordner. Ich habe nicht mal Leitz geholt, ich habe mir die Secondhand-Marke geholt. Leitzi. Leitzi. Und habe mir die eingeheftet und ja, jetzt ist mein Leben zumindest oberflächlich unter Kontrolle, aber allzu viel hat mir das auch nicht geholfen. Ich habe mir eine Münzgeldsortiermaschine gekauft. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Applaus.
Ich dachte, das ist mit den Fehlkäufen.
Leute lieben das. Nein, ist kein Fehlkauf. Naja, zum Teil. Ich habe das aufgestellt und ich habe sehr viel Kleingeld.
Ich dachte mir, ja, ganz geil, angenommen, ich bestelle mir was zu essen oder so, ist es immer geil, ein Euro an 50 in der Nähe zu haben, um dem was zu geben, Trinkgeld mässig. Da ich aber nur meine grosse, alles Kleingeld, was ich habe, kommt in einen grossen Eimer. Ich auch, ich habe auch den Eimer. So, der grosse Eimer und es war erst Briefumschlag, wenn ihr euch erinnert, noch, fokussend Woche zwei. Das ist gut, die Storyline geht weiter. Die Storyline ist beim Eimer angekommen.
Ja, irgendwann hast du eine eigene Wohnung.
Und jetzt bei der Minzgeldsortiermaschine angekommen.
Irgendwann komme ich in so einen eigenen Tresor bei der Bank.
Und da habe ich dann angefangen, ich finde es auch ganz gut,
ich habe eine Serie geguckt, habe mir dann mein Eimer hingestellt
und dann habe ich angefangen, Serie zu gucken
und nebenbei einfach das Geld in die Sortiermaschine zu packen.
Und so weiter. Es hat nur einen Schlitz, das war ein bisschen nervig,
du kannst es nicht reinkippen, sondern man muss nacheinander. Aber was machst du denn dann mit dem sortierten Geld? Genau, so, sowas habe ich nicht gedacht. Die waren nicht so teuer. Ich gucke also die Serie und nach der fünften Münze war die voll. Dann war die einfach komplett voll und dann habe ich gedacht, okay, ich habe jetzt aber nur zwei Eimer, wie mache ich das jetzt am besten? Und dann habe ich das Kupfergeld wieder reingekippt in den einen Eimer und das andere Geld in den anderen Eimer gemacht. Aber was ist denn letzten Endes dein Ziel? Wohin willst du damit? Ursprünglich war mein Ziel, zumindest, also erst mal mein Ziel, mein Geld zu sortieren. Warum? Ich glaube, tief drin habe ich gedacht, ja, dann kannst du ja noch dieses Einrollding holen und dann kannst du es direkt bei der Bank abgeben und dann kannst du es auf dein Konto überweisen.
So, das habe ich aber sehr schnell verworfen. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, zumindest rationalisiere ich mir den Kauf, dadurch, dass ich zumindest die zwei Euro, ein Euro, fünfzig Cent Dinger für mich gesondert habe, um halt direkt das grosse Kleingeld vom kleinen Kleingeld zu sortieren. Dann hat das auch nicht funktioniert.
Und mittlerweile habe ich jetzt, jetzt habe ich zwei Eimer, einen grossen mit ein Cent bis zehn Cent und einen anderen mit zwanzig Cent-Stücken und ein Euro, fünfzig Cent und zwei Euro sind in der Geldsortiermaschine. Du hast ein Eimer nur für zwanzig Cent. Das hat exakt nichts verändert. Er ist nicht ganz voll. Er ist ein kleiner Eimer, so ein Kindereimer. Es ist wirklich unglaublich verwirrend jetzt. Es hat nichts in meiner Situation whatsoever verbessert. Also naja, ich erkläre mal ganz kurz mein System. Ich komme jeden Abend nach Hause und tue das Kleingeld aus meinem Geldbeutel in den Eimer. Wenn ein Zwei-Euro-Stück dabei ist, lege ich es in meinen Schrank auf einen Stapel Zwei-Euro-Stücke. Das heißt, ich habe einmal einen Stapel Zwei- Euro-Stücke und einen Eimer mit Rest. Wenn jetzt ich was bestelle, nehme ich von einem zwei Euro-Stapel ein zwei Euro-Stück und gebe es als Trinkgeld. Wow, er gibt zwei Euro, alles klar. Ja, die grösste Münze. Hast du nämlich schlecht gemacht. Immer die grösste Münze. Die kleinste Münze? Nein, die grösste. Also da bin ich stolz darauf, dass ich diese Regel für mich entdeckt habe. Trinkgeld, immer die größte Münze. Und dann bist du nämlich sicher,
in jedem Land.
Es gibt auch dann so eine 5-Euro-Münze, gibt es ja auch.
Nein, gibt es nicht. Ganz selten.
Doch so Sammlerstücke. Wenn du die in der Wohnung hast,
was machst du dann? Ja, dann ist System Error und dann muss ich selber ihre Hand anlegen.
Aber letztlich,
merkt euch das, egal in welchem Land der Welt ihr seid,
Trinkgeld, im Zweifelsfall
immer die größte Münze. Viel Spaß in Amerika, wenn ihr den Leuten 25 Cent gebt und sagt, Ciao, ich sage den Ciao. Es gibt Dollar-Münze. Es gibt die Dollar-Münze. Das schneide ich raus. Die größte Münze immer. Ja, das war nicht so gut, tatsächlich jetzt. Aber ich habe mittlerweile ein gutes Quittungssystem, einfach auch einen Eimer. Wo einfach zack rein, Quittung rein. Ich komme jetzt in ein Alter, wo man Quittungen sammeln muss, wo man auch sagen muss, langsam wird es ernst. Ich habe oft in meinem Leben den Satz gehört, jetzt beginnt der Ernst des Lebens für dich. Das hört man immer, wenn man in die Schule kommt, das hört man, wenn man dann aufs Gymnasium kommt später, sogar wenn man einfach in den Kindergarten kommt. Aber ich glaube, jetzt beginnt der Ernst des Lebens für mich. Jetzt, wo man anfangen muss, die Quittung zu sammeln, um Steuern zurückzubekommen. Ja, und vor allem, wo man auch anfängt, so ein Quatsch mit, das war jetzt ein Geschäftsessen oder sowas. Also, wo man einfach alles... Da muss ich auch mal sagen, da habe ich gemerkt, was für ein Mensch du bist. Wir waren schön koreanisch essen. Erstmal muss man sagen, ich dachte koreanisch, ich dachte koreanisch wäre folgendermaßen, ich dachte, es wäre eine all-in koreanische Experience. Man kommt, man fährt in eine Strasse, wo schon Läden sind, die annähernd koreanisch anmassen. So ein bisschen ein kleines Chinatown in Köln, haben wir nicht. Es ist ein normaler Laden. Ich dachte, da sieht es wenigstens ein bisschen koreanisch aus. Nope, hochmodern, mit grossartigen Grills im Tisch und so weiter. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt sollen, sorry, aber wenigstens die Bedienungen sollen koreanisch sein. Nope, einfach komplett knallhart deutsch, dann, jetzt sprech mit mir wenigstens irgendwie, lass die Karte zumindest ein bisschen koreanisch, wo sind die koreanischen Schriftzeichen, irgendwas? Nein, jetzt zumindest das koreanische Essen, gib mir koreanische Essen, nein, es war einfach nur, das Einzige, was anders war, war, du hattest einen Grill im Tisch und konntest Sachen drauflegen, die du auch hier essen kannst. Das wusste ich schon mal nicht. Und dann gab es zwei Gerichte zur Auswahl. Einmal das Gericht ohne Schrimps und einmal das Gericht mit Schrimp. Tatsächlich bezahlt die Firma alles an diesem Abend. Floh und hinten ist neben mir und sagt, ich hätte gerne die ohne Schrimps. Wo ich mir sagen könnte, das ist doch nicht dein fucking Ernst. Ja, aber da waren andere Sachen dazu, die zusätzlich dabei waren. Da waren Tofu dabei, die bei Schrimp nicht dabei waren. Dann sagst du trotzdem, ich hätte das gerne, aber auch mit den Schrimps. Und dann zwingst du so in die Gruppe. Weil du die Schrimps haben willst. Natürlich, die waren umsonst, die Firma bezahlt, das sind Geschäftsessen. Da holt man maximal viel raus, für die ganze Gruppe. Ja, es tut mir leid. Ich hab's verbockt. Ja. Bock auf eine neue Rubrik? Ja. Ey, ich steck... Ups, ich steck... Ich steck Arbeit in diesen Podcast. Ich will dir noch ganz kurz den Emoji zeigen. Ja. Also wir gehen erst mal noch mal zur alten Rubrik zurück. Vorsicht, Achtung. Hier. Guck dir mal die Ordner an hier, Volume eins, Volume zwei. Oh, ganz oben haben wir das klassische ... Moleskin? Ja, nee, das ist dieses schwarz-weiße, was man in der Mathe hatte oft. Moleskin. Nein, du bedurrst das falsche Wort, weil ich hab ... Moleskin sind einfach nur schwarz oder nicht. Dann gibt's jedenfalls einen roten Ordner, es gibt einen grünen Ordner, einen blauen Ord es gibt so viele Ordner, es gibt einen orangenen Ordner und dann gibt es noch das Ringbuch, das gelbe Ringbuch.
Der grüne muss weg, der grüne Ordner muss weg. Es gibt sechs Ordner. Sechs Ordner als Emoji.
Und es gibt keine Pokerchips. Es gibt keine Pokerchips und es gibt keinen Typen, der zur Tür rausgeht. Quatsch.
Doch, es gibt einen Typen, es gibt eine Tür und es gibt einen gehenden Typen.
Achtung, die neue Rubrik.
Ich kann dir leider nicht helfen, ich weiß nicht, worum es geht.
Ich würde gerne...
Achtung, mach mal irgendeine Melodie von Nine Inch Nails.
Nine Cringe Nails. Die Cringe-Rubrik bei podcastufo.de. Wow, hab das, ganz kurz, ich hab gerade die Melodie von Social Network gepfiffen, die von dem Frontmann von Nine Inch Nails komponiert wurde. Es war gerade ein mega nerdiger Rubrik anfang. Perfekt. Ja, gut, dann gucken wir, wie es weitergeht. Und zwar, ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert und ich habe alte Spuren von mir im Internet gefunden, denn, wie man in Social Network so schön sagt, The Internet is not written in pencil. It's written in ink, Mark. Genau. Das macht das Zitat immer ein bisschen merkwürdig und schlecht im Alltag anwendbar. Kategorische Imperativ, Komma, Zoe, funktioniert auch nicht, selten. Warum wurde die Kritik der Urteilskraft komplett an Bob adressiert? Warum, Immanuel? Ich denke, also bin ich Andrea. Und ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert und ich habe alte Spuren von mir im Internet gefunden. Und es gibt ja so manche Phasen im Leben, auf die ist man nicht so stolz. Ja, aber offen sieht die so sehr, dass man sie nochmal im Podcast erwähnt. Ich bin gespannt. Naja, es gab eine Zeit, da war ich im Filmfehlerforum aktiv. Ja, Filmfehlerforum, Filmfehlerforum Florentin, das hatten wir schon auch. Filmfehlerforum Florentin. Und ich habe meine alten Einträge im Filmfehlerforum gefunden. Und es gab einen
Beitrag, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, sag mal, hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Was ist
denn bei dir los? Also ich wusste, dass ich früher ein pedantisches Arschloch bin, war, aber ich
wusste nicht, dass ich so ein pedantisches Arschloch war. Und da habe ich einen Post, also ich habe
Aber bin, war. Aber ich wusste nicht, dass ich so ein pedantisches Arschloch war. Und da habe ich einen Post, also ich habe einen Thread eröffnet damit. Das ist auch schon so ein Ding, es gibt für alles einen Thread. Wer einen Thread eröffnet, hat ein Problem. Und da ging es um den Film Der Herr der Ringe, die zwei Türme. Türme. Und der Film, den ich sehr oft gesehen habe. Und ich gebe dir jetzt den Text und du kannst hier mal einlesen, was ich damals geschrieben habe im Filmfehlerforum. Hier unten, der untere Text. So, Florentin schreibt sehr viel zum Filmfehlerforum. Achtung. Die Elben, die in Helmsklamm kämpfen, sind in erster Linie Bogenschützen. Sie ziehen die Sehne jedoch technisch nicht korrekt. Ihre Armlinie verläuft beim Ziehen der Sehne so, dass der Ellenbogen nach unten zeigt. Dadurch hätten sie aber einen ungünstigen Zugwinkel, weil die Armmuskulatur so nicht genug Kraft hat, um den Bogen zu spannen. Korrekterweise wird die Sehne durch eine Bewegung gezogen, bei der vor allem die Schultermuskeln eingesetzt werden und der Ellenbogen
parallel zur Schulter nach hinten gezogen wird.
Gedankenstrich
für diese vielen Gedanken, so wie es
bei Legolas der Fall ist.
Gruus Honey.
Das ist es bis zu der Zeiten.
Gruus Honey. Gruß, Honey.
Gruß, sexyer Junge, der nervig ist, wenn man neben ihm im Kino sitzt. Weil die ganze Zeit sagt, das kann mit der Armmuskulatur aber nicht hin. Ja, vor allem, das ist meine Definition eines Filmfehlers, dass die Elben in Helmsklamm nicht korrekt ihre Bögen spannen. Ich finde das so gut, dass du die Elben auch akzeptierst, finde ich auch geil. Aber deren Armmuskulatur scheint doch sehr humanoid zu sein und dementsprechend ist die Allenbogenmuskulatur nicht richtig angepasst. Aber wie geil, und danach hätte er doch so gefehlt, nee, deswegen nur zwei Sterne. Ich konnte ihn nicht mehr genießen. Keine Anschauempfehlung. Wer auf Authentizität steht, nicht für diesen Film. Wow. Oh Mann, Alter. Das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht. Aber du bist ein bisschen noch so. Manchmal scheint das so ein bisschen durch, aber interessant, das war extrem. Also das ist schon sympathisch. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, warum Leute dich die Fettigen. Also ich bin nicht pro Mobbing, aber ich finde, Mobbing hat, also die Wurzeln von Mobbing sind schon immer da. Also ich sag mal so, Leute, die gemobbt werden, geben den Leuten oft auch einen guten Grund. Du sagst, Mobbing ist verdient. Ich sag, Mobbing ist nicht richtig, aber. Also oft muss man auch mal genauer hingucken. Das ist dein Zitat. Mobbing ist nicht richtig, aber. Mobbing ist nicht richtig, aber. Das ist mein Zitat. Ja. Holy shit. Oh Mann. Das war eine harte Zeit, aber es ist einfach dieses, also was ich auch zum Beispiel oft merke als Reaktion auf Moin Moins oder aufs Podcast-Ufo ist, dass wenn Leute ein gewisses Wissen haben, sie das unbedingt teilen wollen. Ja. Und unbedingt denken, dass es alle interessiert und dass wenn wir über was reden und dann schreibt jemand in die Kommentare, nein, es ist aber nicht so, korrekterweise ist es so und so und so. Aber denkt ihr dann, wir sind die dümmsten Leute der Welt? Also dementsprechend so viele Nachrichten, die wir bekommen, wo uns Dinge erklärt werden, die wir humoristisch anders benutzt haben im Podcast, denkt ihr auch, was glaubt ihr denn, wie wir sind? Was glaubt ihr denn, was wir wissen? Offensichtlich nichts. Ihr denkt, wir sind die dümmsten Vollidioten der absoluten Welt. Ja, aber es ist... Aber trotzdem hören sie uns. Es ist ein Phänomen, das man gut nachvollziehen kann, wenn man selber in der Position war. Wenn man selber viel weiß. Naja, aber es geht nicht darum, es geht darum, dass man sein Wissen für so unfassbar wertvoll und so unglaublich wichtig hält, dass man es einfach jedem präsentieren will. Gab es Antworten darauf? Das bezweifle ich sehr stark. Ja, ich auch, aber das würde mich mal interessieren. Das bezweifle ich sehr stark. Direkt Beleidigung, direkt instant. Halt deine Fresse! Ich glaube, das war dann auch der Punkt, wo ich das Filmfehlerforum endgültig verlassen habe. Aber man merkt irgendwann, man ist mächtig geworden. Wobei ich glaube, wenn jemand diese Haltung nachvollziehen kann, dann Leute im Filmfehlerforum. Oder nicht? Deine Filmfehlerforum-Freunde? Die werden das noch verstanden haben. Diese Haltung. Du, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich hätte nie viele Freunde im Filmfehlerforum. Aber sind nicht alle Filmfehlerforum-Freunde genauso, würden die nicht genauso schreiben? War nicht jeder Beitrag so, oder? Nein. Nein? Nee, worum geht es denn eigentlich, Filmfehler zu finden? Hier ist ein Mikrofon im Bild. Ja, sowas halt, das waren so klassische Sachen. Nee, jetzt finde ich's nicht mehr. Aber ja, sowas in der Richtung. Ich hab letztens wieder Ocean's Eleven gesehen und hab auch da gemerkt, dass einfach wirklich viele Film-, viele Logiklücken einfach drin sind. Es gibt ja diesen sehr bekannten mit den Flyern, die unmöglich da reinkommen wären. Aber ist mir auch eigentlich egal. Ist total egal egal, ja, absolut egal. Ich checke auch immer wieder aufs Neue nicht, wie sie das gemacht haben und bin immer wieder amazed, wenn ich dann nachher bei Wikipedia die Handlung durchlese. Ah ja, stimmt, genau so war es. Es ist schon einfach so geschrieben, dass beim ersten Mal gucken, würde ich sagen, hat das niemand sofort gecheckt, dass man da die Flyer nicht drin sehen kann. Überhaupt nicht, Aber ich meine, es gibt ja zum Beispiel diesen gesamten Handlungsstrang, wo Saul diesen Koffer in den Tresor bringen will.
Der gibt sich als irgendwie reicher Typ aus, der sagt hier, ich habe hier einen wichtigen Koffer, der soll in den Tresor.
Wie heißt der nochmal?
Leimen Serga.
Und der muss in den Tresor, weil in dem Koffer sind diese grünen Kristalle, die der Sprengstoff sind.
Genau.
Und dann können die von Young im Tresor von innen an die Tür eingebracht werden.
Ja.
Aber er tut da auch noch so Senderstöpsel draufstöpseln.
Und dann fragt man sich, wo kommen die her?
Na, die hatte er ja in seiner Box drin. Der kam ja in dieser Box rein, da war er drin eingesperrt mit begrenzter Luft. Und Endgrills. Und hat da Sachen, wo man sich fragt, warum können nicht in dieser Box auch einfach die grünen Kristalle drin sein? Oder die Flyer. Nein, da sind zu viele, aber wo man sich diesen ganzen Koffer hätte sparen können, man hätte einfach die Kristalle da reintun können. Und es hätte genauso gut funktioniert, weil ja auch diese anderen Sprengstoffmaterialien und der Mensch, der da drin versteckt war, auch so in den Tresor kommen konnte. Also man hätte sich das alles sparen können. Oder es gibt einfach viele künstliche Spannungsmomente, wie zum Beispiel, dass der nur 30 Minuten Atemluft hat, weil er so eine Sauerstoffflasche hat. Gebt ihm zwei, gebt ihm drei von diesen Sauerstoffflaschen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Das ist Soundtrack cool. Ich sage nicht, dass es den Film schlecht macht. Mir fällt es ab. Wie viel haben wir? Wir haben zehn. Machen wir acht. Das sind dann so die Lieder-Scenes, wo man denkt, Leute, das brauchen wir echt nicht. Wo man gesagt hat, ja, ich glaube tatsächlich, Steven Soderberg ist ja nicht doof. Ich glaube teilweise, dass er gesagt hat, dass er im Cutting Room gesass und dann, weil es kann ihm unnötig im Skript aufgefallen sein mit den Flyern, sonst hätte er das nicht gedreht, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube, man kann mir vorstellen, dass so eine typische Sache, die man dann im Cutting Room, wenn man dann zum achten Mal die Szene guckt, fällt einem auf Fuck. Aber dann sagt man sich auch, ja, ist aber auch ganz geil eigentlich. Ich glaube, viele Sachen, die an Filmen kritisiert werden, haben die Regisseure sehr wohl auf dem Schirm, aber die haben einfach gesagt, okay, im Sinne der Spannung und so, und die meisten werden den eh nur einmal gucken, komm, lass es drin, lass es diesen künstlichen Spannungsmoment kreieren. Ist doch cool. Vor allem hat er in dem Moment, in dem es aufgelöst wird, so viel Denkaufgabe, den eigentlichen Plan zu verstehen, wie die mit dem SWAT-Themen reingegangen sind. Und oh, was war jetzt echt, was war nachgedreht im Tresor. Dass der Zuschauer sowieso schon über so viele Dinge nachdenken muss, dass das völlig untergeht. Vor allem, es wurde auch im neuen Star Wars kritisiert, dass die Verfassungssache nicht so richtig Sinn ergibt, weil die Resistance flieht ja. Und dann geht denen der Treibstoff aus. Da die im Weltall sind, kann man sagen, es geht kein Widerstand, also bleiben die auch sehr, sehr schnell noch. Die First Order wird aber die ganze Zeit weiter beschleunigt. Theoretisch haben die ja auch noch Treibstoff für Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Da haben Leute vorgeschlagen, ja die könnten doch einfach mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit so lange Lichtgeschwindigkeitssprünge machen, ganz kurze, bis sie vor der Resistance sind, um die dann abschießen zu können.
Ja, klar kann man das machen, wäre halt ein mega boring Film. Was ist das für ein Film, wo die ganze Zeit jetzt ganz kurz und wieder aufhören und dann sind sie 400 Parsecs zu weit.
Sorry, sorry, jetzt mal zurück. Jetzt, wenn wir das nur acht Mal machen, müssen wir ungefähr davor sein,
wo man denkt, ja, okay, alles klar, wo Ryan sonst auch so sagen muss,
wollt ihr diesen Film haben? Okay, wir cutten den euch zurecht.
Ist dann halt scheiße, das fand ich so lustig, weil die Vorstellung,
klar, kann man viele Logelücken weglassen,
aber dann halt für den Preis eines schlechteren Films.
Aber stimmt, du brauchst gar keinen Treibstoff,
um dich hier im Weltall zu bewegen. Ja, aber die Verste hast ... Ja, aber die First Order beschleunigt ja weiter. Von daher holen die die ja ein. Also während die Einladen keinen Treibstoff mehr haben, beschleunigen die First Order, die verfolgt ja weiter. Ja, aber du wirst ja nicht langsamer, wenn du kein Gas mehr gibst. Nee, aber du wirst schneller, wenn du noch mehr weiter Gas gibst, während die Einladen nicht mehr beschleunigen. Wenn du weiter beschleunigst, wirst du schneller.. Ja, bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Nee, du kannst unendlich schnell sein. Nein. Bis Lichtgeschwindigkeit halt. Wenn du auf der Autobahn fährst und dein Gaspedal drückst und die Gaspedalposition behältst, hört ein Auto irgendwann auf, schneller zu werden. Ja, ja, liegt an deinem Auto aber. Das liegt an deinem Auto, weil das runterregelt irgendwann. Im Weltall kannst du unendlich, du kannst ja bis Lichtgeschwindigkeit theoretisch beschleunigen, im Star Wars Universum. Wirklich? Ja. Was ist das für eine Regel? Ein Auto kann nur 120 fahren, also können alle Dinge, die beschleunigen, die ganze Zeit nur 120 fahren. Warum kann ein Flugzeug schneller fahren zum Beispiel, wenn es die jensten beschleunigt? Nein, weil natürlich jedes Fahrzeug eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit hat. Aber du kannst nicht einfach dadurch, dass du länger beschleunigst, eine beliebig hohe Geschwindigkeit erreichen. Nee, natürlich nicht. Lichtgeschwindigkeit wäre Schluss im Weltall. Nein, aber auch so nicht. Aber guck mal, die können doch auch theoretisch Lichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen. Aber ganz kurz, beim Auto sind wir uns einig. Das ist irgendwann runterregelt, ja. Was meinst du mit runterregelt? Also beim Lamborghini kann auch schneller fahren. Ja, aber auch ein Lamborghini erreicht niemals Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Ja, weil dann der Motor irgendwann sagt, nope, no way. Ja, aber das ist doch die Höchstgeschwindigkeit, dass der Motor irgendwann sagt, nur wir reden gerade von einem Vehikel, was theoretisch Lichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen kann, deswegen meine ich. Ja, im Lichtgeschwindigkeitsmodus, das ist ja nochmal was anderes, aber der Lichtgeschwindigkeitsmodus ist ja nicht, dass man einfach so lange Gas gibt, bis man über zwei Jahre hinweg. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie es ist, wenn du keinen Luftwiderstand hast, aber auch da muss es doch irgendwie... Also meinst du, auch jetzt schon könnte moderne Rakete im Weltall Lichtgeschwindigkeit erreichen, wenn sie nur lang genug beschleunigt? Darauf möchte ich keine Antwort geben. Die Frage ist mir... Kann ich meinen Anwalt ... Nee, er ist gefragt, ob ich nicht glaube, dass ... Die Frage war mir zukompliziert gestellt. Cut drei Minuten zurück. Glauben die Leute eigentlich, wir sind komplett bescheuert? Yo, piu, piu, piu, piu, vollkommen dusselig. Ich bleib bei meiner Meinung, auf jeden Fall. Gerade bei einem, der Motor sagt halt irgendwann, ich kann nicht weiter beschleunigen, weil ich eine Maximalgeschwindigkeit erreicht habe. Du siehst ja auch die Drehzahl hochgehen. Aha, die Drehzahl. Der Motor sagt ja irgendwann, irgendwann kommst du in den roten Bereich. Beim Lambo zum Beispiel kannst du so weiter beschleunigen, wenn du auf Gas drückst komplett, beschleunigt er so lange weiter, bis er irgendwann in dem roten Drehzahlbereich. Die Drehzahl eines Motors hat irgendwann, nein, Feierabend. Bei dem Raumschiff der First Order würde ich mal behaupten, sagt die noch lange nicht Feierabend, ab einem gewissen Punkt mit Sicherheit. Aber auch im Weltall, wenn du weiter beschleunigst, weiter Treibstoff fortbordernst, wirst du einfach auch schneller. Ich sag auch, eine Rakete hat eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit. Komm, ruf mal an, der Riebel an, wer muss doch die Nummer. Ich sag auch, dass eine Rakete eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit hat. Ich rufe Philipp Hauptmann an. Aber ganz kurz, bevor wir uns jetzt im Gespräch in Widersprüche verstricken, was genau behauptest du?
Ich behaupte, dass du, sobald du weiter beschleunigst, schneller wirst. Die einfache Theorie ist, rein theoretisch, in theoretischer Physik kannst du Gravitation erzeugen, wenn du die ganze Sekunde nur ehrlich mit 9,81 Meter pro Sekunde beschleunigst, kannst du ja, hast du die ganze Zeit, wirst du weiter beschleunigt, wirst du schneller und kannst dementsprechend wie auf einer Erde stehen, wenn du auf der Rückwand des Flugzeugs, der Rakete, wenn du das Weltall rast, dementsprechend musst du, und dann musst du es immer weiter beschleunigen. Und wenn du immer weiter beschleunigst, wirst du halt immer schneller. Aber auch wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt einen unendlich hohen Berg runterfällst, hört deine Fallgeschwindigkeit auch irgendwann auf, höher zu werden. Ja, genau, aber nur weil du einen Luftwiderstand hast, der zur Masse, die ja größer wird, die schneller du bist, ähnlich genau groß wird. Und ohne Luftwiderstand wirst du irgendwann Lichtgeschwindigkeit erreichen? Ja. Aber das ist ein neues Beispiel, weil dann müsste irgendwo Gravitation sein. Warum ist das anruhig? Ich bin mir sehr sicher. Ich bin mir mittlerweile auch nicht mehr ganz sicher. Also wir sagen, wir haben eine Rakete, die im Weltraum ohne Luftwiderstand beschleunigt. Im Weltraum beschleunigt, da musst du auch keinen Luftwiderstand aushebeln. Naja, ist man nah an einem anderen Planeten dran. Nein, im fucking Weltall. Ich will's einfach. Nein, so grosses Weltall. Da ist der Filmfehler. Da hast du wieder hundert Satelliten in der Nähe, die dir im Weg rumfliegen. So, da ist er pedant. Also. Ich behaupte, wenn man beschleunigt, wird man immer schneller im Weltraum. Du sagst, du hörst irgendwann auf, zuhör zu werden. Eine Rakete beschleunigt im Weltall. Ohne Luftwiderstand, mit unendlich viel Treibstoff. Erreicht diese Rakete irgendwann Lichtgeschwindigkeit oder ist irgendwann Schluss? Hallo Philipp, du bist gerade im Podcast-UFO, wir haben eine Physikfrage für dich. Sehr gutes Timing. Ja, sehr gerne, ich freue mich sehr. Hallo, Stefan. Hi, grüß dich. Hi. Du, folgendes, es geht darum, eine Rakete beschleunigt im Weltraum. Okay, so weit, so gut. Kein Luftwiderstand, die Rakete beschleunigt mit ihrem Raketenantrieb. So, die Frage ist jetzt... Welchen Raketenantrieb? Die Frage ist jetzt, wird die Rakete immer schneller, immer schneller, wenn sie weiter beschleunigt, oder erreicht sie irgendwann eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit? Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Beispiel. Kannst du ja, was ist noch eine Vermutung? Also, Stefan behauptet, die Rakete beschleunigt immer weiter, bis sie irgendwann Lichtgeschwindigkeit erreicht. Ich behaupte, die Rakete wird irgendwann nicht mehr schneller. Wie kommst du darauf, dass sie nicht schneller wird? Ja eben, du Vollidiot, das habe ich da auch gerade gesagt. Was soll denn da verhindern? Ja, weil so ein Raketenantrieb ja auch irgendwie eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit hat oder sowas. Nein, der kann ja Treibstoff ausgehen oder sowas. Warum hat ein Auto eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit? Habe ich ihm auch erklärt, weil der Motor eine gewisse Leistungskraft hat. Ja, was hält das Auto zurück? Die Luft, du Vollidiot, das habe ich ihm auch gesagt. Ja, und die Energie, die im Benzin steckt, oder dass der Motor nicht generell unendlich viel Kraft erzeugen kann. Reibung und Luft, du Vollung. Also soll das heißen, Stefan hat recht. Leider, wieder mal Stefan. Ach, was heißt denn hier, wieder mal so ein... Wieder mal recht gehabt, das Wording von Philipp Hauptmann. Vielen Dank. Ich drei Lichtjahre. Und dazu zum Beispiel gibt es die Idee, wie man da hinkommt, indem man einen sehr neumodischen, lichtbetriebenen Antrieb benutzt und dann eben effektiv einfach lange, sagen wir mal, schiebt. Und dann irgendwann sind die Dinger, diese kleinen Däten, die man hinschicken möchte, sehr, sehr schnell, weil man sehr lange drauf ballern kann. Das ist eine Idee von Stephen Hawking, mit Laser beschleunigen, habe ich auch von mir bekommen. Hast du denn The Last Jedi gesehen? Ja, habe ich gesehen. Wieso? Ja, da gibt es doch die Szene, dass das große Schiff des Imperiums, Raumschiff, hinter dem Rebellenschiff herfliegt. First Order. First Order. Aber das ist eine ganz philosophische Frage, also jetzt über die Logik von Star Wars zu diskutieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch die Zeit reicht. Aber ich muss sagen, da kann ich gerne mal die impöse, höhnliche Meinung mit reinbringen. Warum, habe ich nicht gefragt. Gibt es da nicht bessere Ideen als das, das ist ja echt ein komischer Aufhänger für den Film. Aber gut. Das war Philipp Hauptmann. Aber ganz unabhängig davon. Ich erkenne mir das mal. Aber ganz kurz. Warum gibt es Treibstoff und Schilde auf einmal in Star Wars, wo kommen die denn auf einmal her? Schilde gab es immer schon. Ja, aber nicht so, nicht so hundertprozentig, wer alles abdenkt, es war immer nur so komische Wabe. Klar, deswegen mussten wir auch noch Endor und den Schildgenerator kaputt machen. Ja, aber so, dass da irgendwie was aufgehalten wird, das ist doch ganz neu, dass dann Schüsse nicht durchkommen oder so. Aber ganz kurz, du würdest sagen, dass das durchaus, wenn Star Wars jetzt nach unseren physikalischen Gesetzen funktionieren würde, wäre das unlogisch, weil das verfolgende Schiff ja immer schneller werden würde, weil es ständig beschleunigt. Aber die anderen auch, bis die Treibstoffe ausgeben. Ja, aber es wird ja gesagt, die haben die gleiche Geschwindigkeit, die holen sich nie ein. Die anderen sind sogar schneller, die sind leichter, deswegen sind die schneller. Und solange die Treibstoffe haben, können die die nicht einholen. Aber ganz kurz, wenn der... Aber das ist natürlich schon so, dass das scheisse dumm ist manchmal, also in vielen Fällen,
deswegen macht man das ja auch nicht.
Okay.
Weil wenn es einfach immer nur schneller werden bringt, ja erstmal nichts, also auch so,
du weisst, was du wo du hin willst.
Vor allem ein großes Problem, wenn du ganz schnell bist, musst du auch wieder bremsen,
wenn du stehen bleiben willst, und das musst du ja auch alles mit deinen Turbinen machen,
deswegen ist das also gerade in der heutigen Raumfahrt nicht so eine schlaue Idee, wahnsinnig
schnell zu werden, weil du dann für jeden Scheiß, den du machst, immer extrem viel
Energie brauchst. Du hast auch immer mehr Energie.
Du willst gerade so schnell werden, wie du kannst, wie du musst eben.
Nun gut,
mir gefällt deine Antwort nicht, aber ich beuge mich
der Wissenschaft. Stefan, du hattest recht.
Vielen Dank, Philipp, für dein
Fachwissen. Tschaui. Mach's gut.
Tschau.
Ist richtig
geknickt.
Das heißt aber, beide Schiffe müssen auch genau die gleiche Beschleunigung haben. Nee, die Resistance ist schneller einfach ein bisschen, weil die leichter sind, haben die ja gesagt, deswegen sind die schneller. Also dann wird der Abstand grösser. Genau, wird man ein bisschen grösser, nur irgendwann geht der Treibstoff aus. Seht das richtig, dass Zuhörer, die Oceans Eleven und The Last Jedi nicht gesehen haben, 80 Prozent dieses Podcasts skippen können?
Die wollen es irgendwie ihrer Freundin zeigen oder ihrer Mutter und dann, nee, gleich sind die wieder lustig. Gleich reden sie wieder über Lakritze, das verstehst du auch, du magst doch Lakritze. Ich spiel kurz vor, ja, bei Last Jedi kann das Eule. Aber kurz zu deiner pedantischen Vergangenheit. Ich war ähnlich, ich war tatsächlich ähnlich,
mir ist neulich eingefallen, weil ich das spannend fand.
Es gab damals ein Börsenspiel.
Oh, das gab's doch auch.
Genau, ein Börsenspiel, wo man quasi fiktiv,
an einem gewissen Startpunkt Aktien kaufen muss,
mit Spielgeld in so einem Programm,
und dann an den Realtime-Aktienwerten halt die Gewinne erzielt
oder halt Verluste erzielt.
Und am Ende an irgendeinem Punkt, nach drei Monaten, ist Stopp,
Und wer am Ende an irgendeinem Punkt, nach, glaube ich, drei Monaten, ist Stopp und wer am meisten Geld in seinem Depot hat, gewinnt und ist dementsprechend der Sieger. Ich habe das damals ein bisschen ernst genommen. Also man muss sagen, ich habe es sehr ernst genommen. Meine Tante ist Anlageberaterin, ich sie direkt angerufen und habe gesagt, kannst du mir sämtliche Analysebögen schicken und so und sie gehört, oh klar, warum nicht, weird, komisch, das ist ein achtjähriger Fragen, ne ich war schon ehrlich, ich war lächerlich alt, ich war glaube ich wirklich 16 oder so und habe dann von ihr die ganzen Analysebögen bekommen und geguckt, ja und BMW hat da und da stellt die Quartalzahlen vor, okay und hier gibt es auch noch Nachhaltigkeitspunkte für BMW, direkt, okay, gekauft, habe mich jetzt reingenerdet, so richtig eklig reingenerdet, auch sämtliche soziale Kontakte abgebrochen fürs fucking Planspiel Börse. Und dann habe ich mich reingenerdet und tatsächlich massiv gewonnen und habe dann halt den ersten Preis gemacht. Und dann habe ich 200 Euro bekommen. Und dann musste ich zur Sparkasse gehen. Und dann kam auch die Presse, der hellbige Anzeiger hat ein Foto gemacht. Und ich dachte mir so, cool, richtig geil, bis ich dann gesehen habe, gegen wen ich da eigentlich die ganze Zeit gespielt habe. Was dann einfach achtjährige, kleine Jungs und Mädels waren, mit grossen Augen, in diesem typischen Alter, wo man noch diese Umhänge-Portemonnaies hat und so einen Schlüssel um den Hals, die sich gefreut haben, dass sie da sein können. Und dann kommt Stefan Tietze, der lächerlich groß ist, doppelt so groß wie alle anderen, vom Team Buy or Die reingelaufen und hat den ersten Preis gemacht. Fucking 200 Euro, unnachhaltig Preis, Preis, auch an Stefan, kein Team. Ich habe nicht immer ein Team gehabt, einfach alleine hingelaufen, Preis genommen. Ich, ich, ich, auf dem zweiten Platz der Inklusionskindergarten geht leider leer aus, schade. Kein Geld fürs Kinderhaus-Piets, in den Preis hat Stefan Tietze mit Bayo Deigo. Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, wirf's mit Geld durch die Gegend hier. Sehr schön. Hier, steck's in dein Portemonnaie um den Hals, ey, steck's dir einen, bück dich. Komm schon. Dein Hello Kitty-Portemonnaie hier, nimm's da. Planspielbörse, das war der Scheiss. Ich gucke mal gerade, ob es da mal irgendwie Artikel zu gibt. Bei uns gab es auch Planspielbörse. Und ich habe mich auch ein bisschen reingefuchst. Ich hatte aber wenig Ahnung, ich war aber sehr ehrgeizig. Und was ich gemacht habe, ich habe ständig die Aktien wieder neu gekauft und wieder verkauft und wieder neu gekauft. Und dann habe ich wieder meine Entscheidung bereut, habe meine Aktien wieder verkauft und wieder neu gekauft. Und am Ende alles kaputt gemacht, weil ich zu viel verkauft hast. Gebühren haben mich aufgefressen und es war kommender Bullshit und auch irgendwie am Ende, die ganz langen Mathematik-Cracks haben sich reingearbeitet und am Ende hat das komplette Slacker-Team gewonnen, aus der letzten Reihe, die am ersten Tag gekauft hat, ja, was sollen wir alles von unserem Geld kaufen? Ja, kauf halt irgendwie Allianz. Alles auf Allianz. Und dann, ja, okay,
cool, jetzt haben die gewonnen.
Wirklich? Ach so, wir haben das Passwort verloren.
Yeah, das gibt doch in den Artikel.
Tristan, Fabian, Stefan und Kevin heißt das Team. Tristan, Fabian, Stefan und Kevin
gewinnen im Verbandplatz
und noch einmal 50 Euro
für Buy or Die.
Sein Foto dabei? Ja, aber ich habe ein bisschen übertrieben. Ich habe die wesentlich jünger in Erinnerung gehabt. Ich weiß aber nicht, die waren aber auf jeden Fall nicht in meinem Team. Die waren irgendwie von der Kreis. Aber wie erfolgreich, du hast nämlich diesen Warren Buffett-Blick. Einfach so dieses, ihr seid alle arm wegen mir. Auch dieses Hemd, alle haben sich so. Ey, du dachtest ja wirklich, du bist der nächste Gordon Gekko, einfach so ein bisschen so. Ich ziehe das in die ganze Finanzwelt. Ich glaube, Gordon Gekko war auch meine erste Idee für einen Namen. Erster Name für meinen Gekko. Oh, gut. Aber das war wirklich, aber ich finde es ganz interessant. Du kommst von deinem Weg FilmfeuerForum, ich komme von Buy or Die und zusammen machen wir das Arschloch-Podcast. Ja, und du hast noch 250 Euro mitgenommen. Und ich nichts. Und ich habe mich 16 Jahre in so einem dummen Forum rumgetrieben. Das finde ich wirklich lustig. Ja. Ich habe neulich ... Ich habe irgendwie angefangen, in meinem Zimmer eine Geschichte zu plotten. Und dann habe ich natürlich nichts hingekriegt, weil ich zu faul bin und mich meinen Arsch nicht hochbekomme. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja komm, holst du halt Dateikarten und holst du halt eine Korkwand, holst du halt Pinnadeln und so. Du hast doch schon eine Korkwand. Das war schon so eine Wand. Das war die Geschichte, die ich gerade erzähle. Und dann, und dann ... Jetzt habe ich mal noch rote Bindfäden, um Dinge zu verbinden. Und dann ... Oh Gott, vor allem der Blick von der Verkäuferin, die sieht, dass ich gerade diese Pinnadeln und roten Bindfaden kaufe, und eine Korkwand ... Ich glaube, die Karteikarten hatte ich schon. Aber ... also Korkwand, rote Bindfäden und diese Pinnadeln, die hat wirklich so, es war so, geht das aus ihrer Hand zur Kasse oder aus diesem roten Knopf unter der Kasse, einfach so, ruf den Filalleiter an oder kannst du die Sachen bei mir kaufen? Das war mir so hart unangenehm. Aber den Bindfaden hast du nie benutzt. Nee, ich wollte ihn eigentlich benutzen,
nicht um Dinge zu verbinden, sondern um die Wand
in unterschiedliche Teile zu trennen, in Akte zu trennen.
Und dann ist mir nicht eingefallen, dass man auch Krepppapier benutzen,
diese Kreppbänder benutzen könnte, oder irgendwie was anderes.
Ich habe roten Bindfaden gekauft.
Und dann, während ich das zur Kasse bringe, fällt mir so ein, ach shit, okay, come, judge me, come on, bring it on. Das war echt angenehm. Was machst du gerade so? Fühl mich mal durch deinen Alltag. Ach, viel Zeit, ne? Viel entspannen, ich bade viel, ich erlebe meinen Körper und ansonsten. Es gibt jetzt, wo du was Körper entdecken sagst. Ich habe jetzt von einem Sexspielzeug gehört,
wo das ist halt so ein Flashlight.
Flashlight, also
das deutsche Wort ist nicht so schön. Taschenmuschi
kenne ich nur als deutsches Wort. Gibt es ein anderes,
besseres deutsches Wort? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, ne. Aber Flashlight finde ich nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht sollten wir es auch irgendwie Toschenlampe
oder so nennen. Einfach
wo man halt, wo man sein Glied halt reinführt und das dann vibriert. Taschenschlampe. Vaginal, ja, auch nicht wesentlich besser. Oh. Aber wo man dann, was dann auch vibriert und was dann so Vaginal Verkehr oder Oral Verkehr darstellt. Ich glaube, man kann auswählen, ne, zwischen drei, genau, richtig. All den Best-of-Körperöffnungen, den Top-drei-Körperöffnungen. Genau, alles, er kann alles mitnehmen. Und dann gab es eine Werbung von Rocco Sifredi, diesem Pornodarsteller, und der hat gesagt, 1500 Filme, 5000 Mal Sex, ein bester Orgasmus. Und ich dachte erst, also er hat sich herausgestellt, er meint sich selber. Er hat so viele Filme gedreht, er hat mit so vielen Frauen geschlafen und er war, er hatte damit den besten Orgasmus. Erst habe ich aber gedacht, man kann damit Filme gucken und erlebt dann simultan zum Film die Gefühle einer Person beim Sex. Angenommen, du guckst eine entspannte Game of Thrones Folge, wo es dann irgendwann mal zur Sache geht. So, dann hast du halt deine Toschenlampe an deinem Glied stecken und dann wenn Daenerys mit Jon Snow schläft, mimt die das nach. Dachte ich. Es ist halt immer schlecht, wenn es so eine Parallelmontage ist zwischen immer Schlacht und Sexszene und du immer hin und her geschnitten wirst. Penis ab. Aber ich glaube, was Ähnliches gab es mal. Das habe ich mal gesehen. Das war dann so ein Kasten, wo innen so eine Art Fließbänder drin waren, die auch mit so diesem Gummi-Zeug bestrichen waren, die dann auch so hin und her gezogen haben. Dass du nicht mehr selber bewegen musst, sondern nur dein Glied einführst und es einfach hin und her bobbelt. Und am Fließband. Und das kannst du tatsächlich synchronisieren mit dafür vorgesehenen Pornofilmen. Pornos, ja, das sagte ich nämlich dann auch. Wo halt dann irgendein Praktikant die Vor- und Hinterbewegungen einfach tracken muss. Ja, wie bei diesen Deepbox-Motion-Seats im Kino. Ja, genau. Und dann das irgendwie überträgt oder sowas. Aber da musst du dir bestimmt so einen Treiber installieren und dann läuft der aus und ist der neue Patch und dann so, ach scheiße, jetzt ist alles asynchron und dann habe ich eh Betonschere und dann, ach Gott, das ist ja mit... Vor allem manche Geräte, manche Geräte dürfen nicht kaputt gehen, denke ich mir dann auch. Also, wenn das kaputt geht und man einfach mal sagt, so und jetzt mache ich mal so eine 90-Grad-Biegung und dann steckt halt in diesem technischen Gerät, die ja durchaus auch Defekte haben können, dein Glied, das ist doch furchtbar. Ja, aber dann bist du reich. Ich denke nur, wenn du das bist, bist du reich. Weil dann kannst du die Firma verklagen, komm zum Boden. Das ist dein erster Gedanke? Du kriegst zehn Millionen. Ah, ich bin reich. Ja, du kriegst zehn Millionen. Ja, gut. Gut, das ist die Frage, wie viel ist dir dein Glied wert? Mein erster Gedanke wäre, okay, ich kann keine Kinder mehr bekommen. Ja, aber dafür kann ich Geld bekommen. Ich kann mir Kinder kaufen. Das ist mein erster Gedanke, ich kann mir Kinder kaufen. Naja, das fand ich schon interessant, weil das glaube ich gibt es noch nicht, also jetzt anscheinend doch. Mein Gedanke war, sowas wäre ja cool zu erfinden, dass du halt einen Film guckst und dann nebenbei die Gefühle merkst. Ich glaube, es ist generell bei Filmen so, wenn du die anschaust, solltest du die Gefühle merken. Bei diesen Debux-Motion-Cities hat es ja nicht nur Wasser zwischendurch auch, als dir dann beim Date einfach Wasser eingegossen wurde, wo dann so eine Fontäne in mein Gesicht kam, wo ich mir dachte, was ist das denn für ein Kellner gewesen? Mit wem bin ich das Glas gerade oder was? Mit wem bin ich das Glas gerade? Mit den Wassermolekülen. So wirklich bei jeder erdenklichen Wasserszene, jemand trinkt einen Schluck, Bats, Wasser ins Gesicht. Bin ich der Gaumen, die Zunge? Und dann kam eine Riesenschussszene, wo man so langsam, und dann kam so ein Hauch, als ob jemand so neben dir steht, der pustet. So kurz so ein Luftstoss auf den Kopf, wo ich mir dachte, so führen sich Schüsse an? Geil! Und dann waren auch jegliche Steaks in dem Film, waren weg. Jemand fällt aus dem achtzehnten Stock, knallt auf dem Boden, jemand piekst in seinen Rücken. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das tat offensichtlich nicht weh. Ich weiß nicht, es macht alles kaputt. Da war er auch so ein bisschen bei den Pornos. Das war echt kompletter Bullshit. 4D. Ist das jetzt die vierte Dimension? Wenn ich jetzt Stephen Hawking fragen würde. Ich rufe Philipp an. Ist die vierte Dimension rumgerüttelt? Ich glaube schon, ja. Ich glaube, die fünfte Dimension ist ein Geruch. Ich war noch im Kino und da gab es eine Werbung, die lustig anfing, aber dann nicht lustig gemein war. Ah, ich weiß, was du meinst. Die mit dem Kinder schiffeln. So, ganz kurz. Yes! Pointe versaut, pointe versaut, Pointe versaut. Vielen Dank, denn das ist unsere Strategie. Das fand ich ganz ver... Also erst, die fing lustig an irgendwie. Und ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was da der Gag war. Aber du machst halt einen Gag und das Publikum lacht. Kinopublikum. Geile Werbung, cool. Was kriegt man? Ein Auto oder so? Okay, cool, cool. Nächste Szene irgendwie. Man lacht wieder. Geil. 40 Prozent aller Kinder, die geschüttelt werden, sterben. Ja, das war die, genau, schüttelt niemals eure Kinder, 30 Prozent werden behindert, alle anderen sterben, ciao. Aber man dachte halt noch, wenn man so konditioniert war, geile Szene, geile Szene, okay, sorry. Und dann bin ich als ganze Kino, hat noch gelacht, weil es so konditioniert war. Gag, gag, gag, und dann plötzlich war so ein Vakuum. Man hat so alle, alle, alle Freude, wie so die Dementoren, alle Freude wird aus dem Raum gesogen. Und dann dachte ich mir aber auch, das Wort Schütteln ist nicht gut, um dieses Problem, dass Kinder behindert werden und sterben. Schüttel dein Kind nicht. Ist auch eine lustige Aussage.
Kinder schütteln.
Ich dachte mir, meine erste Reaktion war,
oh, zweite Reaktion, definiere schütteln.
Weil was ist denn zum Beispiel mit dem allseits beliebten Hoppe-Hoppe-Reiter?
Ja, es ist Hoppe-Hoppe.
Ist das Schütteln?
Es ist alles Einschütteln.
Schütteln, Hoppe-Hoppe-Reiter, Bumse-Biene, Rütteln, Schubsen. Was ist Rütteln? Also Rütteln wäre für mich ein seitliches. Aber Schütteln ist nach vorne und hinten. Aber in Rütteln steckt für mich schon mehr Aggression als in Schütteln zum Beispiel. Dieses Schütteln, dieses Schütteln, schön, schön. Was ist Wackeln? Hör auf, um deinem Kinn zu wackeln. Ich fand das ganz falsch. Ich fand das Wording komplett unangebracht dafür. Aber es bleibt in Erinnerung und ich habe seitdem auch tatsächlich viel weniger Kinder geschüttelt. Ich habe da aufgehört, ich habe nach Schlag... Sehr wenig Schüttelprobleme mit Kindern, habe ich auch nie gehört. Hast du mal davon gehört, dass Schütteln zum Problem wurde? Ich habe mal so eine Doku gesehen über so einen Typen, dem ging es richtig dreckig. Weil er geschüttelt wurde? Und die Mutter wurde gezeigt und die Mutter hat gesagt, ich habe den so geschüttelt, der jeden Tag, Alter, der hat so geschüttelt, aber so hochwerfen darf man. Und so am Fuss nehmen und nach unten baumeln lassen? Baumeln. Baumeln. Es ist, glaube ich, nicht lustig, aber es ist echt, es ist auch sehr... Im Moment fand ich es schon lustig, weil es wirklich so ein ... Hey, wir sind alle hier, wir haben viel Spaß, geil, cooler Film, wir schauen Star Wars an so ... Hey, schüttelt eure Kinder nicht. Uff, okay, sorry. Aber ne Leute, ernsthaft schüttelt eure Kinder nicht. Lass das mal. Nee, schüttelt eure Kinder nicht. Grütteln. Hier wurde auch geschüttelt, glaub ich. Was ist, wenn das Kind tanzt?
Darf das Kind sich selbst schütteln? Shake your booty?
Meine Mutter hat mir erzählt, das lässt mich rückblickend echt zweifeln, sie hat gesagt, sie wusste lange nicht, dass sie mit mir schwanger ist und hat dann auch, weil sie auch noch ein bisschen geraucht hat und getrunken hat, ist sie zu ihrem Arzt gegangen. Ja, ich weiss ja jetzt, es ist sehr spät, ich habe noch ein bisschen was getrunken, ein bisschen was geraucht, ist das ein Problem?
Und die Ärztin hätte wohl wortwörtlich gesagt, nee, solange sie nicht wissen, dass sie schwanger sind, ist das auch kein Problem. Das habe ich auch letztens gehört. Und dann denke ich mir, okay, das war keine Ärztin. Das war die Frau, die sich offensichtlich in einem Van oder so untersucht hat, irgendeinem Fabrikgelände, so neben Stacheldraht und Spritzen irgendwie geguckt hat, mit ihrem geklauten Ultraschallgerät. Und dieser Satz kam nicht von einer Ärztin. Aber das habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Und ich hatte ähnlichen Unglauben. Wo wurde sie untersucht? In der Wüste, in der Wüste Gobi, in so einem Schamanen. Entschuldigung, ich muss kurz weiterfahren, es ist wieder grün geworden. Aber habe ich auch gehört tatsächlich, naja, es gibt natürlich schon so Placebo-Effekte und sowas, wo man
jetzt erstmal intuitiv sagen würde,
das funktioniert doch nicht, aber es ist schwer zu sagen.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir jetzt auch
bald unseren ersten Gynäkologengast
hier begrüssen im Podcast-Ufo,
um das zu klären, aber
ich habe es auch schon mal gehört.
Ja, also Placebo glaube ich ja auch dran.
Das macht ja auch alles Sinn, dass es um die Psyche geht und so was.
Aber bei so was denke ich mir, das ist schon ein Problem.
Also ich meine, wenn man raucht die ganze Zeit und jemand Lungenkrebs bekommt,
kannst du ja nicht sagen, ich wusste nicht, dass es Lungenkrebs gibt,
also kann ich ja auch nicht krank werden, weil ich ja gar nicht von der Folge wusste.
Ist ja auch alles ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Du wirst ja trotzdem krank, weil der Körper sagt, holy shit, hier wird es langsam ziemlich düster.
Vielleicht wird das Kind ja auch gar nicht tatsächlich vom Rauchen krank, sondern vom schlechten Gewissen, das die Mutter hat, wenn sie weiß, fuck ich bin schwanger, ich rauche trotzdem.
Und dieses schlechte Gewissen kriecht durch die Adern hin zu dem Kind und macht es kaputt.
Krebs ist im Grunde auch nur ein schlechtes Gewissen, ein zu starkes schlechtes Gewissen. Kriegt doch was durch die Wände. Hörst du das nicht? Hörst du das nicht? Wie der Basilisk. Und wann habt ihr das erste Mal gemerkt, dass es mit Stefan bergab geht? Naja, es gab einige hin. Es gabote Fahnen. Rote Fäden. Und das ist die Florentin-Will-Garantie. Mal im Ernst, hier krieg ich doch was für die Wände. Sag mal, ich hab doch einen Käfer im Kopf, oder? Jetzt mal ohne Witz. Mal im Ernst. Ich sag im Ernst, ich hab doch Maden unter der Haut. Ich hatte eine ganz irrationale Angst vor Kretze sehr lange Zeit in meinem Leben. Man sollte auch Kindern kein Lexikon schenken, weil da sind auch furchtbare Dinge drin. Und dann bei K habe ich irgendwann Krätze gelesen. Und ich habe bei C irgendwann Krätze gelesen und ich dachte, jetzt stimmt alles nicht mehr. Ich habe irgendwann Krätze gelesen und dann war das Bild von diesen kleinen, furchtlichen Dingern, die immer nur durch deine Haut kriechen. Und dann, man sieht die dann auch, wie die durch deine Haut kriechen, dann siehst du so kleine, wie so kleine Pusteln. Aber es sind keine Pusteln, sondern es sind die Tiere, die unter deiner fucking Haut leben. Kannst du die ja nicht totdrücken? Nee, die sind zu schnell. Wirklich? Die sind rasant, die sind fix. Aber bewegen die sich einfach Offroad oder sind die auf Adern oder so? Nee, die sind Offroad unterwegs, glaube ich. Die können schon sagen, nee, jetzt gehe ich hier steil rechts. Die können hin, wo sie wollen. Ich glaube, die sind Offroad, ja. Die können nur hin, wo sie wollen. Aber die Haut ist doch nicht einfach getrennt vom Rest des Körpers. Ich denke mir, doch. Die fressen sich ja, glaube ich, auch durch und so. Wie orientieren die sich denn? Das ist ja ultra schwer, so einen dreidimensionalen Körper zu verstehen. Wenn du da so, komm rein, rein, rein, geht schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, und dann bist du drin und dann so Aber orientieren legt ja fest, legt dann nahe, dass du ein Ziel brauchst. Ich glaube, die haben kein Ziel. Die wollen ja irgendwo hin. Nee, ich glaube, das ist deren, das ist deren Ziel. Deren, ich glaube, deren Ziel ist es, in deinen Körper zu kommen, und dann ist cool, dann ist okay, hier bleibe ich den Rest meines Lebens und such mir Nahrung. Nahrung ist es nicht. Ja, aber die wollen ja bestimmt Eier legen oder so ein Kram. Ja, ja, aber unter der Haut halt. Und das ist ja, ich glaub, da sind die zufrieden. Ich glaub, wenn die erstmal da sind, ist alles cool. Da haben die eine gute Zeit, fressen sich durch, entspannt. Und wenn dir jetzt irgendwie so fünf Kretze kommen rein, du atmest einmal tief ein, sagen die dann so, hey, war cool, ich pack's, ich gehe nach links, du nach rechts, oder hängen die dann noch eine Weile miteinander ab und trennen die sich erst später, oder ist es dann wirklich, dass man sagt so, jetzt haben wir es geschafft, wie so nach einem Banküberfall sagen die Gangster so, hey, cool, wir teilen das Geld, ciao, wir sind weg, oder gibt es dann noch so freundschaftliche Bande? Ich glaube, die legen dann Eier und dann sterben sie schnell relativ, weil das deren einziges Ziel ist überhaupt.
Das ist wie so eine, also wie wenn du ein MMORPG zu Ende gespielt hast oder sagen wir mal irgendwie ein Rollenabenteuerspiel zu Ende gespielt hast und danach nie wieder was vom Charakter siehst.
So ist das auch. Die haben ihr Ziel, die haben einfach ein Lebensziel, Eier legen.
Und dann ist gut. Alles jetzt ist ein Bonus.
So lange ich jeder Tag, wo ich nicht plackgedrückt werde von dieser grossen Hand, die. Alles jetzt ist ein Bonus. Jeder Tag, wo ich nicht plattgedrückt werde
von dieser großen Hand, die manchmal kommt,
ist ein Bonus.
Das ist eine geile Zeit, glaube ich.
Du hast durchgespielt,
also du hast deine Eier gelegt,
durchgezockt, du hast die geile Rüstung bekommen,
du hast inhaltlich viele Rubine
und dann erstmal ein bisschen machen, was man will.
Ja, es ist wie ein Bekannten von einem Bekannten,
dem gesagt wurde, im Alter von elf oder so,
folgendes, du hast nur noch zehn Monate zu leben.
Du hast eine unheilbare Krankheit.
Und er lebt heute noch.
Und dann nenne ich mir auch, geil, eigentlich geil.
Das sollte man eigentlich jedem Kind sagen.
Weil danach hast du doch eine ganz andere Einstellung zum Leben.
Jetzt ist doch alles scheinbar.
Du hast doch eine andere Einstellung zu Ärzten.
Jetzt ist, ja.
Du sollst nicht rauchen.
Alles klar, okay.
Gut, dann gehe ich jetzt zurück in meinen Grab.
Du solltest nicht von dieser zwölf Kilometer hohen Klippe springen.
Alles klar.
Okay, sterbe ich sonst wieder?
Oh, wie ich vor drei Jahren gestorben bin.
Ciao.
Was für ein freches Kind.
Sehen Sie, ich lebe immer noch.
Ja, aber das ist doch geil. Dein ganzes Leben ist Bonus. Alles ist cool. Jetzt hast du, jetzt ist es gut. Tschaui. Ist Rente so oder ist Rente eher so Abspann? Die Ersten stehen auf, gehen nach Hause, Popcorn klebt, am Stuhl. Ich glaube, Rente primär so Bingo und sowas sagt ja auch aus, dass die dann immer noch gewinnen wollen. Selbst in der Rente... Die haben noch Ehrgeiz. Ja, selbst in der Rente denkär so Bingo und sowas, sagt ja auch aus, dass die dann immer noch gewinnen wollen.
Selbst in der Rente...
Die haben noch Ehrgeiz. Ja, selbst in der Rente denkst du so,
die mit ihren blöden
großen Stiften, wo sie einfach nur
auf B19
drücken müssen.
Es ist ein lächerlichen großen Stift.
Es ist ein Stempel eigentlich, oder?
Nein, es ist ein Bingo-Stift.
Diese großen Stifte.
Und dann, da wollen die auch noch
gewinnen. So im letzten Atemzug
Vielen Dank. Das ist ein Stempel eigentlich, oder? Nein, es ist ein Bingo-Stift. Diese grossen Stifte. Und da wollen die auch noch gewinnen. So im letzten Atemzug. Die Susanne hat schon Krebs im Endstadium, die kann schon nicht mehr atmen, die hat auf beiden Ohren nur noch ein Prozent Fähigkeit, sehen schon gar nicht mehr. Aber mit dem dicken Stift will sie noch die Monika ausstechen. Es gibt bei Bingo diesen riesigen Stift, eine riesengroße Spitzheit, wo man dann so drauf tupft und dann die Bingo-Teile anstreicht, die man, aber stell dir mal vor, du machst so einen Bausparvertrag, so Herr Tietz, du musst dir jetzt nur noch hier unten unterschreiben und du so, ich hab meinen eigenen Stift, holst ihn raus einfach und ist deine Unterschrift, dotzt einmal, alles klar. Unterschriftlichen Stempel, das wäre ja immer geil, so ein Riesenstift, so ein grossen. Als Kinder kriegt man ja manchmal in meiner Schultüte zum Beispiel so ein riesen Bleistift, so riesig gross, so einen Meter lang. Müsste man dem Kind nicht einen noch kleineren Bleistift schenken? Ja, genau. Ist doch völlig falsch. Ja, genau, aber ich glaube, das wäre so ein Gag. Und dann dachte ich mir auch, so bei der ersten Mal der Klausur, einfach, hat jemand, mein kleiner Stift ist abgebrochen, hat jemand noch einen Stift? Okay, alles klar, dann muss ich.
Steht auf, legt das Blatt auf den Boden und wie so ein Gondoliere einfach so.
Und dann geht kurz raus, einfach hier.
Wenn wir beide Fenster aufmachen können. Einfach runter.
Danke.
Und dann will ich auch das Geräusch des Schreims.
Und dann, oh, ich habe einen Fehler gemacht.
Sekunde, einmal umdrehen, wie ein Sturm durch das Zimmer.
Mark hängt dran, der kleine Mark, es hängt oben am Radiergummi.
Aufgespießt, die Lehrerin hat ein bisschen Angst vor dem Schüler, weil sie technisch wie eine Waffe in der Hand hat.
Ja, Schulzeit.
Es war eine magische Zeit. Ich habe neulich die Bilder gefunden von mir, wie ich im Krippenspiel gespielt habe. Meine Hauptrolle, ich war die Nacht. Ich war der Sternenhimmel. Man sieht mich, kurz vor meinem grossen Auftritt halte ich beide Schilder runter und bin unglaublich aufgeregt und dann im zweiten Bild halte ich die beiden Schilder hoch, Sterne und es ist Nacht. Man sieht sofort, dass es Nacht. Man würde nicht mehr in Frage stellen, dass Nacht ist. Ah, du hattest einmal Tagschilder und einmal Nachtschilder. Nein, nur Nacht. Und die Tagschilder hast du dann so versteckt? Ich hätte keine Tagschilder, also nie Nachtschilder. Und was hast du tagsüber gemacht? Habe ich die runter, einfach nicht hochgehalten. Ich war immer noch da, aber so wie man am Tag weiß, heute Nacht wird auch wieder Nacht sein, hat man schon gesehen, gleich wird Nacht sein.
Der Nachthimmel.
Und ich hatte wirklich, ich hatte so eine ganz wunderschöne Kleidung. Also guckt mal bei Instagram, wie es aussieht.
Wunderschöne Kleidung.
Fantastisch, ey.
Aber können wir bitte auf der IMDb-Seite von Stefan hinzuschreiben als Rolle der Nachthimmel? Ja.
Was eine unglaublich geile Rolle ist.
Ja, es klingt so ein bisschen wie die Königin der Nacht oder so, Es klingt wie eine große Rolle. Ja. Der Nachthimmel. Ja. Warst du dieses Jahr wieder in der Kirche Weihnachten und hast du ein Krippenspiel gesehen? Nein, nein. Ich habe ein Krippenspiel gesehen. Der Pfarrer hat tatsächlich wieder Jerusalem als Hauptstadt von Israel aberkannt. Wo ich mir dachte, okay, gut. Er hat gesagt, er wollte nicht Trump nennen, aber er hat drum herum geredet und hat dann gesagt, das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Früher hat er auch gesagt, das war ein Kindergottesdienst. Vorhin saß die kleine Maria, die kleine Joseph und diese Babyborn-Christkind. Und dann er steht da vorne mit dem Mikro, ist auch von seinem Pult weggegangen, hat das Mikro so in die Hand genommen und hat also angefangen, so ein Stand-up, halb Stand-up, halb Kult. Der Spot verfolgt ihn. Ja, Spot verfolgt. Wo kommt dieser Spot her? Ist es Gott? Man hat auch nicht wusste, was ist denn jetzt los? Und dann hat er angefangen, ja, da wurde ja neulich auch Jerusalem als Hauptstadt anerkannt und da leben ja auch viele Menschen, die das nicht so sehen, ne, auch mit den Kindern. Die Kinder auch ab und zu erst so auf die Knie gegangen sind, so auf die Knie so, oder? Das ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Und man kennt das im Kindergottesdienst,
wo dann oft den Kindern zum Mikrofon hingehalten wird.
Und wo war Jesus geboren?
Richtig, genau, in der Krippe.
Und dann im Stall, mit dem Esel.
Und wer war doch dabei? Joseph, genau.
Und dann auch, ja, dann wurde Jerusalem als Hauptstadt.
Und warum ist es nicht gut, Jerusalem als Hauptstadt anzuerkennen?
Na, kleine Lisa, was ist der Grund?
Und Lisa so, weil die Palästinenser das liebt. Richtig, Valerie, ja ganz toll. Da hat er gesagt, und deswegen ist Jerusalem nicht die Hauptstadt von Israel. Und die ganze Kirche, ja, yes!
Badapadapa, badapadapa, macht's Ja, yes, badadadadadadadadadadaddienst so politisch zu werden. Das war nicht richtig. Yo, sind wir durch eigentlich? Ja, wir sind durch, ja. Gut, gut, in diesem Sinne. Kommt gut nach Hause. Du schlägst eine schöne Woche, geht baden. Geht, machen wir mal raus,, das Wetter wird wieder besser. Ja, geht mal joggen. Fang mal ein neues Projekt an. Sag mal irgendwie, ich habe Lust, ich mache einen Online-Store, ich verkaufe da was, ich kaufe was ein, ich sortiere was, ich mache einen Blog und sammle da irgendwie interessante Artikel, die ich gefunden habe. Ich kümmere mich mal ein bisschen meine Social-Media-Accounts, ein bisschen mehr Inhalt, ein bisschen mehr Content, irgendwie vielleicht mit anderen kurzschliessen. Und legt euer Geld nicht in Aktien an, sondern Gold oder Wein oder Pferdesperma. Investiert in Menschen. Ja, oder das, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Gehört euch mal einen schönen Wochenendurlaub. Mal an die Ostsee. Ja, das waren Flo und Hint Will und Stefan Tietze.
Und wir heissen das nächste Mal auch, wie er Flo und Hint Will und Stefan Tietze im Podcast UFO.
Macht's gut, die Woche.